can i just say something men are
intimidated by women
generally because there's nothing that
you could actually do to a man it's
going to intimidate him like you're not
stronger than him you know you know i
mean you're not physical we're not we
don't see him but like oh my god we're
intimidated right yeah we you know i
mean like we're not i think um
a lot of the time men understand that
one of the reasons why women tend to
think that they're that men are
intimidated is because
when it comes like i said when it comes
to confrontation because if you look at
it at like an energy thing right
men know what confrontational energy is
we've known it from the playground we
used to get into fires in the playground
it went on into our teenage years we
know what confrontation is and like i
said when it comes to confrontation if a
woman brings that same masculine energy
to us well i can't do nothing
all right
okay like we don't know it's like if i
come back at you with that same
masculine energy we're the bad guy right
we're gonna be back i don't think that's
what i was referring to when i was
talking about so what do you think
intimidating when i was talking about
intimidation i was i was referring to
um kind of
i don't want to say my success but kind
of like my portfolio so when i go to
someone and i tell them oh
i do this this and this and this and i'm
successful i i'm good at it this is
what's going on in my life it's like
oh and i've been
with people
who
haven't
matched that i don't want to say i don't
they shouldn't they don't need to match
what i'm doing but it's like they
haven't
been on a similar level and i and
there's been
a sense of insecurity
from their standards
no ashes wanted to jump in that's
but you're saying that like it mostly
comes from menden because that's like
that seems like a more genuine like a
like general thing like you say that
you're this and that what does it only
meant that that type of way for me
personally is i've only experienced that
from men because men will come into my
life talking about i need to be the
provider i need to be the success
successful one and then they see me and
it's like well as you know
you're the successful one and there's
there's an element of insecurity in that
and from my previous experiences that
has caused the strain because they've
tried to compete with me when it's like
i'm not trying to compete with you i
don't really care about
how much you're doing or how much you're
earning as a competitor you see you see
the men like that say that
what what like what's the general what
do they do like
what's the criteria i mean
there's levels to it i think there's
it's interesting i think from my
previous experiences there's just been
it will be the slide comments every time
i'll say okay like for example if i was
to tell you if i was to go to my partner
now i mean i don't have a problem but
like from my previous experiences if i
was to go to my partner now and say okay
i'm going to podcast today oh why are
you doing that oh you talk too much it
would just be like the little comments
that i oh but you're always doing this
or you're always doing that it'll just
be like the little things to try and
like bring me down
and it's like
why why because if you were truly if you
were secure in what you were doing what
i'm doing shouldn't be an issue for you
but understand that intimidation via
success
is not gender specific
but from my experience it has been but
that's that'll be subject
i'll i'll say i'll say doesn't that mean
you're picking badly
that yeah that means you're just picking
bad guys maybe you're picking insecure
man i'm picking some dead up man thanks
for that
no no
thank you for that thank you for that
because you're saying you're saying
you've experienced it many times and
that's why you have that that view on
men because
if i like
i think i see it as a in a general way
if i say i'm an actor writer i don't i
don't always get from a type of whipped
um only certain people that are they
don't like it i get it from all types of
people men and women in it you know i
mean it's just
fair enough i i don't think like
this is a thing right
so i don't know your life right however
when you're speaking like this and
you're saying okay yeah maybe you've had
to become more masculine right to get in
to get ahead
maybe your masculine
is picking feminine men
whoa
because
masculine and feminine
compliment one another
they do they complement one another
maybe you're picking feminine men maybe
you're picking insecure men
she's deep in that love way
you know one thing i've always said and
i actually want to hear your opinion on
this i've always
oh that one hurts that one
[Music]
i always said to myself i said
i have the i recognize that i have these
masculine features
um but i've always wanted someone whose
masculinity overpowers my femininity
no so i think that's where the
submission comes in no no hang on it's
not his masculinity overpowering your
femininity
you want his masculinity to overpower
your masculinity
because men only overpower
that's what i meant i wanted yeah sorry
that was my favorite that was my
phrasing his masculinity should
overpower my masculinity to bring out my
feminism two masculines can't work right
and so
and so when that's where that's where
the femininity comes in that's why i
swear that's the extent to i agree with
which i said in the beginning that i
don't mind submitting to a person in
that aspect because yeah so you
basically saying that's what you're
saying you want so you want someone to
conquer you
what do you mean you're saying you're
saying you want his masculine to battle
your
your your mask i just i don't want to
always feel like i have to do everything
it's like when it comes to a
relationship i think i've because
because i've always been the person
who's like kind of the provider who's
the masculine energy it's like i don't
want to have to go into a relationship
and feel like i have to do it there you
go like what like what um sarah like
what sora said that means you're just
picking bad guys because you're always
putting men you're always putting
yourself in that position but the reason
why you're picking feminine men is
because you're in your masculinity there
you go
you're not in your femininity and so
when it comes back to the video that
we're talking about with ellie she was
talking about being feminine and being
submissive
right and that's the reason why she got
a man and i feel like a lot of women
out there today
[Music]
who
are single and wondering why they're
single i'm not saying that's you bums it
excuse me i'm saying a lot of women that
are out there they don't realize because
masculine men do not want to deal with
masculine women they want feminine women
and so
when i've heard a lot of women say yeah
i'll be feminine for the right man
femininity
to me is not a switch that you turn on
and off it's just something that you are
just like if you're masculine you're
masculine if a man said to a woman
i'll be masculine for the right woman
don't be like oh
what was this guy talking about like you
would get yeah like joked on honestly
deep it right think of it like this if
if i as a man come up to you and say
oh like i'm a feminine guy until i meet
the right woman
how are you going to feel you're not
going to feel attracted to me so
therefore it's one of those things where
you have to come
and be
what you would want
your partner to
be in a relationship
so
because me personally i'm not going to
give up my career life that's not going
to happen so my question is okay how do
i still maintain if i want to be in a
relationship
how do i maintain
the career life
and still balance
a feminine energy
ah that's a good question so what you
will find is that
most women who have
husbands and long-term partners
are feminine women
i would say
i'm not even trying to be disrespectful
you're gonna have a hard time
finding a man if you're in your
masculine you're going to have a hard
time
finding a man that's willing to deal
with a masculine woman right i tell you
what men will do and this is going
somewhere and i'm just being realistic
men will have sex with masculine women
they will not take them as a long-term
partner because they know there's going
to be too much conflict in the
relationship
right but that doesn't understand why
are you laughing that's an answer to the
question
he's right but that's to answer the
question
so you're saying i can't have a career
no i'm not saying you can't have a
career
but that's what i'm saying you didn't
answer the question i'm saying you have
to become just like ali said in the
video right because even with our jobs
her jobs like were assistance to the
so like i said so to to become
a lot of the time to become a wife you
have to be more feminine you have to
find your feminine and the thing is
you're cool because you're young
right so you've got time i'm just saying
you've got time a lot of women have
spent so many years in their masculine
energy that it just becomes part of
their character right and then they're
in their
mid-20s 30s and they're like oh why
can't i find a man inside you've been
masculine all your life no man's willing
to deal with that masculine energy so
when it comes to marriage and i think
like a lot of women well not a lot of
them some women talk about marriage and
that's like that they want to be married
they want that long-term partner they
want it they want it they want it right
and i think it's something that both men
and women want they want that secure
partner they want that secure life right
but
understanding the dynamics and the way
it must work is where i think people are
failing okay i have another question
just follow on from that i'm sorry i'm
surprised you must be asking questions
no sorry this is interesting i think
okay so
we're talking about submission
and we're linking that to femininity is
that the only feminine colon feminine
quality you look for in a woman
no it's one of them um
ash go on you answer that as a man as a
young man
as a young man thing is with me yeah
like
i just want peace
that's all i want if you could offer me
peace
then then cool because i'm the day
relationships are not all sweet and
lovey-dovey there's gonna be arguments
on that
the thing is i just want to um if we do
have an argument i want to find the
solution within it if you can come to me
as my girlfriend or my wife and just we
can find a solution together then cool
but um
being submissive is in a way where
because even like i said people see
submissives where oh
the man just tells me what to do and
then i'll do it no it's not like that
like it's just
being in your feminine you know what i
mean it's not everyday battling it's not
every day
going a man's face i'm pointing at him
and showering him nah sometimes sit down
and talk
baby you hungry what's your favorite
dish
yeah i feel you i agree and yeah like is
that the only quality that a woman's
supposed to have no no but the thing is
femininity is a thing that men are
attracted to just like
masculinity is a thing that women are
attracted to right so
there are masculine things like a man
can
as a woman you know that you can see a
man do certain things he may be he may
fix something
he may solve a problem you know oh my
god
that was not
that turned me on in some way same thing
with men
right men see women do certain things
and they're like oh my god yeah and this
and it's mostly to do with the feminine
not to do with the masculine right and
you know what i'm saying just like women
are attracted to that masculine energy
men are attracted to feminine energy and
i'm saying
when it comes to like i say going back
to the video
when ali was saying it and so many women
were talking about oh my god this sounds
like slavery you're talking about
submission all of this kind of stuff is
just like you know what like she maybe
she's figured out maybe she's cracked
the cold
if that's what you want if this is what
women want at the end of the day which
is a marriage right maybe she's cracked
the cold and i'm and i'm sure you know
i wouldn't bet my house on it but the
women that were messaging saying oh my
god i probably single women yeah i agree
with that i got a question for you okay
because like he said like
you've had like many situations with men
like saying that they feel threatened or
intimidated by your position
so what do you look for in a guy
i mean i look for the masculine features
then why do yourself in the positions i
need to hear that no but like i think
they they present themselves as that i
think i i have my so you think i have
the things that i look forward to so
it's a facade
it's a facade yeah so it's not like it's
not like i see you do nothing just sit
at home all day and think oh yeah you're
attractive no it's not that thing it's
like okay cool i like men who go to the
gym i like men who work on something i
like i like people who are doing
something for themselves
um but it's when
i then get to know them a little more
there's like actually
the work ethic you know i think i think
you know i think men have been quite of
the generation have been quite good
doing what they've been quite good in um
in expelling their masculine energy
meaning being aggressive being like
look look at me don't [ __ ] with me type
energy right
however
in my
personal point of view a masculine man
is logical
he's a leader
he's strategic he's more than just oh
don't don't f with me energy right so a
lot of the guys that are displaying that
you know look at me energy i'm i'm this
alpha type of energy when you get down
to the crux of it they don't know how to
lead they don't know how to strategize
they don't know what they're doing with
their life but they do know how to expel
their masculine energy like that then
hold then
what what can we do as men to fix that
problem then you can be more you can be
more you can think more because i think
a lot of guys women were watching two
guys fight and get turned on
right
you know what i'm saying because they're
expelling their masculine energy do you
know what i mean so women you're
laughing because it's true
it's true like that's so
right but
just because two men can fight and expel
their masculine energy which women are
attracted to yeah it doesn't mean that
man is going to be a strategist doesn't
mean that man is going to be a thinker
doesn't mean that man's going to be
logical but the thing is what you have
um
mistook for masculinity is just an ex
the expelling of the masculine energy
like they will watch two guys box
they'll watch mm and they'll be like oh
my god those guys are so sexy when you
do that
that man could be a bloody idiot at home
yeah it could be a fool i wanted to
touch a point that you were talking
about peace earlier yeah and i think
a lot of women know that men want women
to be their peace but i think from what
i've seen from some of the women around
me is that they often
where
the struggle lies is that
sometimes men not all men but like a lot
of men don't like to show their emotions
and that makes life a lot of a lot
difficult for us because we want to come
into your life be like okay we want to
help you
if there's something going on in your
life like let us in like
you've got
[ __ ]
legally stop the cats
hold on over seriously because there's
been so many times where i've been in
situations where it's like okay i want
to be there for you i want to be able to
surprise support you with the love and
care that you need but you're not going
to let me in fact you're not going to
talk if you cry in front of a woman
what's the next move for them it depends
it depends what girl it depends what
girl if i can't like my if i cry in
front of my my girl like my wife he
she i i hope not even hope she the one
that i pick she will know how to
react to that
but i would prefer not to
if i do
i'll prefer not to
the point is you don't let us in how
could you explain it
okay there's a reason why there's a
reason why okay cool because out of the
day
okay hold on if we do cry you're gonna
you just cried the other day you know
what
i'm saying
now you know what it is you know
because if we do you will see us in
you'll see us in a type of way
i think
right and that's what happens like women
when they see men they want men to be
right when they see men in their
feminine energy a lot of the time and
i've said i was on the same podcast and
i said something right i said look
women have been asking men to be more in
touch with their feminine side yeah for
three four decades now because with the
feminist movement right the feminism
said be more in touch with your feminine
side
i grew up in a time where i the coin was
turned metrosexual okay i don't know if
you don't remember that that's when men
were coming out of their masculinity and
they were asking men to be more in touch
and the term metrosexual was coined
right and there was men that would
monitor the feminine side they would go
and get pedicures they would go and get
manicures they would go and do this and
then what happened was right
when that man turns up
women are not attracted to him it's true
they're not attracted to that feminine
man they're attracted to a masculine man
always have been always will be so men
need to stop seeking i'm saying women
asked men to do it because like i said
before
men
want the [ __ ]
and they will do anything to get it
generally right so if i've got to
this is what men were thinking if i've
got what i would become a little bit
more feminine and i get the [ __ ]
all right
and then they've done it
and then we were like oh
yeah
you're too soft too you're too soft and
all that do you know what i'm saying so
it's like why are you crying
i think it comes down to balance when it
when you're in a marriage you're going
to need communication you're going to be
you're going to be able to talk to your
partner like you were saying earlier how
if there's an issue you want to be able
to solve it together how are you going
to do that if you don't if you don't
show your vulnerable attack side at
times i'm not saying okay every single
day you wake up in the morning start
crying in front of me that's not what
i'm saying but i'm saying there should
be there should be a balance like you
should be able to sit down in front of
me and talk to me if there is an issue
and i feel like a lot of men just don't
do that and there's communication
barriers so switching back to the
subject here that was very interesting
switching back to the subject about
marriage because ali in the video was
talking about marriage right and being
married um
is your goal as a man and is your goal
as a woman to get married i want to get
married yes yes
i feel like i think
shout out to samuels but um
i think that actually don't like that
but continue uh
go and continue i think the meaning of
life is people on it that we come to
this become we were born as one person
and we are able to create create a
community of people from our offspring
in it and i see
i see marriage is more as a duty
people say there's like happiness behind
there that happiness comes with it but
you you're married for family to create
one that's what i think
is your goal to get married
yes
i would i would once again get married i
want to have a family when i'm older um
yeah let me ask this question then on
leading
do you think this generation that's
coming up
are prepared
to be wives and husbands
no
no
you know it is
um
shout out to city girl culture shout out
to you boycott you see what i mean
that's what i mean
don't want to marry city girls we don't
want that we want like we want a wife
i don't think a lot of city girls are
our wife
and i don't they don't ask me a wife
there's one thing that um
that i know
um
this is this is actually my i don't know
i'm saying this a lot of modern women or
not a lot most one of them most modern
women don't have to be a wife
you understand
it's like it's like
like it's like going into something
you're not reading the manual i agree i
agree with that but i i wanna i think
that comes from
a place of
not
being not seeing that as much i think
there's the divorce rate has increased
heavily and so i think there's now a lot
of people coming into broken families um
where marriages are declining divorces
are happening and so
there isn't
a big template
for there isn't like a lot of templates
as to what a good marriage should look
like i think for me i'm quite privileged
because the church that i go to my
pastors are married they've been married
for years and they're currently doing a
series on what a good marriage should
look like in um doing it god's way and
that's really useful because okay cool
the church can see
these are these are two people who are
successful in their marriage okay great
they're talking about their roles as men
and women and what they should be like
in a marriage is great it's lovely
that's a good template that's the manual
as you wish to say it but for people who
don't have that in their lives it's like
well i don't know where i'm supposed to
look because my parents aren't married i
i look i i don't see marriage in my
family a lot so it's like where am i
supposed to seek that manual that you're
talking about
we're going to continue that you know
we're going to read some super chats
first but we're going to continue yeah